-It's always good to see you.
Thank you for playing
any game with me
and doing bits. I love it.
-Come on, man.
That was -- it's crazy fun.
-I was almost going to see you
on the "SNL"
Christmas episode
with Paul Rudd.
-Yeah, that was an almost
catastrophe
that almost happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's you and whoever...
-It slammed into the wall.
-...at the end of --
at the end of the night.
-That's just five people when it
should be 60, but...
-Tom Hanks, yeah.
And Che and...
-Yeah. Poor Paul Rudd, man.
He'll get his gift back, though.
-Yeah, I mean, I felt bad
for him,
because I was gonna
come in for that.
That's when I tested positive.
-Oh, so your business
is out there?
So we can say that you...?
-Yeah, we can say, yeah.
-Okay, cool.
-Yeah, I talk of it, yeah.
-But that was dirty. You were
living dirty that morning.
[ Laughter ]
-I wouldn't call it that.
But what was that week
like though?
Because that week you planned
to have a show, right?
-Yeah, we were working like it
was a regular week on the show,
and you know, we -- Tom Hanks
was coming because it was going
to be Paul Rudd's fifth show,
you know?
-Yeah, five timers.
-Four and half.
But he still got his jacket.
-Yeah.
-But yeah, we were working
like a regular week,
and then numbers were just
going crazy in New York,
and by Saturday, you know,
NBC people just called it.
They were just like,
"Send everybody home."
We figured out a way to like,
you know, keep whoever.
I was asked to stay and a couple
other people, I guess
and a small crew, and then,
you know,
we put on whatever show we had.
Luckily, like they didn't call
it until Saturday,
so we were able to get
some like new stuff
that had been pretaped and
stuff that week or whatever.
But yeah, it was crazy.
It was not --
-Thanks for being there,
and thanks for putting
on the show.
-I had to represent
for the cast, baby.
-Come on, bud.
That's what I'm talking about.
Show must go on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The show must always go on.
-Another great season of "SNL"
this year,
but one person that stuck
out that stole
the show is Dionne Warwick
came on the show
and was so funny.
She was great.
-Did y'all see Dionne Warwick?
-It was so good.
-She was incredible.
-She was incred-- She nailed it.
But here's one thing,
she tweeted at you
before she was on the show
because somebody said
like hey, you should do "SNL"
this season.
And she said, "That's a question
for the persons
who run the show,
Lorne or Kenan."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Okay, back story.
Ego Nwodim has been doing an
incredible impression
of Dionne Warwick.
She does a Dionne Warwick show,
and I think it, you know,
kind of triggered her radar.
So I think Black people migrate
towards each other.
So for some reason she thinks
that I represent "SNL"
and she can speak through me,
you know,
to get her message across.
Like, if we see a crowd
of people and we see
a Black person in the crowd,
we're going to go them
and ask them like, "Who made the
chicken?" I guess.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I just -- I gotta announce
today that
"SNL" is coming back next week.
-That's right.
We are back next week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ariana DeBose.
-Ariana DeBose, that's right.
-Roddy Ricch.
-Yeah, Roddy Ricch.
He's amazing.
-That's going to be a good show.
-You like that song
Roddy Ricch did?
-The last time
we saw each other,
I was just talking
to the audience,
but we were in D.C. for Lorne.
Lorne got
the Kennedy Center honor.
-Yeah, congratulations to him.
-Yeah, that was --
Dude, you killed that night.
-Thank you.
-I forget what joke you told,
but you crushed.
-Okay, so my first opening joke,
I just thought was like,
you know,
just a cool opener or whatever.
But it was --
it killed everyone.
-Killed.
-So it was...
-Something.
-You know, you usually don't get
invited to Washington, D.C.
to talk about your boss,
especially in front
of the president
and especially under oath.
-Yeah.
-Right?
[ Laughter ]
Just alright?
When you're in D.C.,
destroyed the room.
-Yeah, I told you though
afterwards, they cut to Biden.
The president was there,
and he was clapping.
He was like laughing.
-Joe Biden clapped.
-Like, under the mask you can
tell he's laughing,
laughing, laughing.
And I go, "Just crushed."
-That was crazy.
A shout out to David.
He was producing that show,
and he wrote that.
He knows his audience.
-He knows his audience, man.
They knew it.
But I thought it was so --
-Straightforward,
strict law jokes.
[ Laughter ]
-I liked it, because, you know,
it's fun to have funny friends.
-Yeah, it's the best.
-And funny people.
We did bits all the day long.
-It's the best.
Like, whenever we are able to --
because we don't get
to see the elders much,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, once you leave the show.
-Thank you.
-You know, so it's nice
to get around.
-I'm the elder now. Wow.
-You're one of the --
our elders. You know?
You're definitely my big brother
for sure.
-Appreciate it.
-But ain't that sweet?
But it's true.
I was 25 when I came
to the show.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-It's when you first start.
But it's fun to be
around you guys,
also the new cast,
Steve Martin was there.
-That's what I'm saying.
As soon as I walked in,
Kevin Nealon and Steve Martin
sitting there, like,
going over jokes.
-Kevin Nealon did
the funniest bit to me.
The whole day was all bits.
-Yeah.
-Amy Poehler doing bits,
Kristen Wiig doing bits.
The best.
-Exhausting, but it's the best.
-The whole day was bits.
-Yeah, very passive aggressive
hazing.
-Everyone was doing bits,
and I got to the hotel.
I go, I'll have a couple, like,
an hour of non-bits...
-Right.
-...just so I can --
-Just to relax and shut the
brain down from bits.
-Yeah, shower off the bits.
-Yeah.
-But I get -- I get out --
I get out of the car
and Jim Downey
is standing in front
of the hotel.
Here comes one
of the best writers.
-Here comes one of greatest
from the beginning.
-From the beginning?
-Yes.
-Of "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-Haven't spoken to Jim
in probably three years.
-Yeah.
-Just life happens.
But I go, "I have to do a bit."
-Immediately.
-I haven't seen the guy.
He's one of the funniest dudes.
-No matter how tired you are,
there must be a bit
that's gotta happen.
-There has to be a bit so I came
out and I go --
it was the hotel and then they
had like two -- like a parking
garage and they had two poles
so that your car, you know?
And I got out of the car
and I go,
"Excuse me sir, is this to the
Washington monument?"
-Classic.
-Because I'm in D.C.,
and there's this tiny pole.
-Great.
-You know, in front of the...
And he --
without missing a beat --
he goes, "A lot of people assume
that that is, but it's not.
It's actually --
it's actually this one."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did a bit.
-Amazing.
-That's the thing about the
environment of "SNL,"
like you're around
such genius minds.
You haven't spoke to the
guy in three years.
-Yeah.
-And you jump into
a bit like that.
-I want to talk about "Kenan"
by the way, and I want to talk
about your Emmy
nominations and all this stuff.
-Me?
-Let's talk about "Kenan."
More with Kenan Thompson
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.